in my generation when you say Martin you
don't have to say his last name
everybody knows who you talking about
my parents had red foxes Sanford and Son
we had Martin Lawrence and the Martin
show the show that made you rush home
from work and you and your family sat
around the TV and watched and laughed
your ass off
and everybody talked about it at work
the next day that was one part of
Martin's Legacy
the most the but the most important part
the number of people he influenced
namely me
I had a friend named Raul and Puerto
Rican George who worked for Russell
Simmons and he gave me and my brother
Jim some tickets to see Martin the whole
step Jam
out of all the comedians that performed
that night the only one I remember was
Martin his funny was effortless
he made me want to do and succeed in
comedy he made me believe I could do it
a few months four months later I
performed on Def Jam
I thought that would be the last time
meeting him because out of nervousness I
smacked him on and he introduced me and
passed me to Mike I thought it was a
good pass
we ain't dropped the mic
might get in the drop not the woods I
thought he was mad at me and even hated
me but to my surprise he called me a
year later
I woke my son to school and when I came
home my wife Sabina said my alarms just
called you I said yeah right Martin call
me he'd call me 10 minutes later he
called
okay he called me back and he said
what's up Wild Boy cause that's what he
used to always call me Wild Boy remember
that he's called you and Billy used to
call me wild boy what's up Wild Boy and
after a short time on the show Martin
and Kenny Buford wrote the real Hustle
Man
for for me which changed me and my
family's life forever
because of that we moved out of the
ghetto
but we still ate Franks and pork and
bean juice
thank you my friend
thank you very much when you get a star
in the Walk of Fame in Hollywood it's he
meant you as a legend but Martin you
have been more than that to me and so
many others you are my brother
and a mentor and I'm so happy to give
and giving you and Sean Lamkin your
roses you will always always be my OG I
love you Marty Ma
because uh
me and his brother was out the country
recently and I walked in the room and he
said hey man I want you to do me a favor
I'm gonna get a star would you come
so I'll fix my schedule so I could be
here uh my only regret I ever made not
coming to one of these was when Cedric
the Entertainer got one I was out the
country then but let me tell you
something about this brother right here
this brother is the lick
he is the reason a lot of us are
standing out here today if you are in
stand-up comedy if you have held the mic
since the Def Jam days you're a dead
gratitude to this brother right here
because this dude was the reason he
Martin Lawrence was the reason that Def
Jam was a huge success see no matter who
the Act was the acts could suck but
Martin Lawrence breathed life into that
night man this dude right here was the
greatest mimicker of all times he could
take a situation and turn it into comedy
if you were sitting on that front row
and one of the acts that just went off
and he just stunk up the room Martin
fixed it man this dude's improbability
is surpassed by none in the business
you're looking at the coldest memica
ever born in the comedy industry today
and that's that damn Martin Lawrence
right here
please understand I know what I'm
talking about I do this here these cats
over here they do this they know who
this dude is this is the legitimate
truth man I've never met a cat that was
more humble with it they gave more black
people opportunities in Hollywood that
Martin Show gave producers opportunities
camera me and opportunities he gave
Caterers jobs he gave wardrobe people
job that show was black from the front
of the time your ass came through that
gate to the back he hired us and made us
recognize and then they made him the
highest paid sitcom star after
um okay Bill Cosby
and it's going good
but still Bill's still great though
regardless as to what happened but he
started making that kind of money and I
jumped in the sitcom game I never made
his money because I just couldn't make a
bigger hit as him but he has been an
inspiration to me he has inspired
thousands def jams spawned more stars
than any comedy genre in the history the
Kings of Comedy was born out of Def Jam
all them cats over there was born out of
Def Jam everybody you see today
was born out of Def Jam and they was
born by the Def Jam because this man
right here made that show the most
incredible piece of work in comedy in
his history Martin Lawrence uh trishina
said I didn't know he didn't have a star
if this dude I'm sorry
if this dude don't have a star they need
to take all of them about the ground dig
all these damn things up ladies and
gentlemen Martin Lawrence it's that dude
thank you
I just want to thank all each and every
one of y'all for being here and showing
me this love and uh I thank God so much
for this blessing and his honor so I
want to read uh what I have for you to
say to you and um
thank you
um
I love you all as well I love y'all as
well
first I would like to give honor to God
in which all things are possible
thank you to the Hollywood Walk of Fame
Hollywood Chamber of Commerce and bet
for recognizing my sense of body of work
and making this possible thank you to
Steve Harvey Lynn Whitfield and Tracy
Morgan
for presenting me with this prestigious
honor as I stand here very gracious and
humble
I would like to give honor to my mom
whose continual guidance from above has
molded me into the man I am today
she instilled the importance of being
true to myself and by doing that I've
been able to bring laughter to so many
thank you to my three beautiful
daughters
Jasmine
Ayanna and Amar
the three of you are part of the best
gift given to me I love you all so very
much
thank you to the cast and crew of The
Martin Show especially Tisha Tashina
Carl and Tommy we made a great team in a
true Testament to Teamwork Makes a dream
work thank you to my family and friends
who hold me down through thick and thin
y'all have encouraged me to show up at
my best and I appreciate I love and
appreciate all of you for that thank you
to my agent and business manager of whom
I have been with most of my career thank
you to my lawyers my management team and
my publicist I want to also take this
moment to give a big thank you to my
fans without your loyal yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes
without your loyal love and support this
moment would not be possible you all
have supported my career without
wavering I appreciate the new generation
of Martin fans who push me to strive for
excuse me
continue Excellence the blessing of my
extraordinary gift of humor has and
continued to help me many others
spending time and creating all the
memories possible with my family and
friends are most important and everyone
that truly knows me can attest I am
honored to have my career flourished as
I persevered through many adversities
and here I still stand if I can pass one
thing on to those coming after me it
would be to board your dream bus with
confidence Grace and humility
and ride it to the wheels fall off
[Applause]